[Music]
sally thank you another number that
continues to grow
nevadans who have fallen victim to
unemployment fraud
here are still many unanswered questions
about how it's happening in the first
place and it's an issue that the i-team
has been following pretty closely
vanessa murphy joining us now live with
more tonight
denise many nevadans have been notified
they failed for
unemployment which is news to them their
identity may have been stolen the system
didn't catch that it was fraudulently
applied
and money was paid to a scammer
from a rapper who made a song bragging
about unemployment fraud and was later
arrested for the crime
to a mail carrier who prosecutors say
was part of a scheme to use
addresses on her route to help collect
the debit cards
employment departments are overwhelmed
due to job losses from the covet 19
pandemic
schemers see an opportunity and fraud is
so bad
nevada's department of employment
training and rehabilitation
also known as dieter is still analyzing
the numbers to figure out how much money
it paid to people who
shouldn't have received it what happened
i think initially
is there was a desire to pay as many
legitimate claimants as possible
as fast as possible mike schmidt runs a
las vegas i.t
company and he's on the deter strike
force a group trying to solve problems
at the agency
including fraud he says his team tried
to match claimants with department of
motor vehicle records
they're finding alarming patterns and
alerting law enforcement
we found in one case
2000 claimants that shared the same
mailing address
schmidt says the system was built for
convenience one reason why fraudulent
applications weren't caught
before the money was paid everybody
could go register
so nobody had to hack into anything
nobody had to break into anything
but personal information is being stolen
to file
fraudulent claims alisa cafferata who
heads dieter says it's not happening
within the agency
what we're seeing and what other states
are seeing is that this is
a result of data breaches that have
happened to other companies and the
information is out in the
dark web and the criminal activity
is certainly concerted
the i-team has been trying to find out
how the information is stolen
in the first place reaching out to
agencies like the fbi and the u.s
postal inspection which investigate the
fraud that's something we're still
looking into
and i don't want to comment too soon on
that
we don't have a concrete answer as to
where they're getting that information
from
the question is well then how do you
stop it if you don't know how it's
starting yeah that's a good question
and that i don't have the answer for but
you know the only thing we can do is we
can you know preach prevention
just for people to check to make sure
that they haven't had unemployment filed
in their name and if they
find out they have to report that right
away the i-team obtained the numbers for
some public employees who have become
victims
clark county reports out of its
approximately 10 thousand employees
1120 have been the subjects of
fraudulent claims
the city of north las vegas reports 282
las vegas reports 568 and
henderson reports 615 while victims are
urged to report fraud to law enforcement
and deter
caferotta says employers can play a
major role in stopping it also
we give them a notice that a claim has
been filed on an employee and several
times
those employees are still working so as
soon as they
log into their portal and let us know we
can stop payments on those claims
so one complaint we've heard from
viewers that that
they report the fraud to deter and law
enforcement and they don't hear
anything back i asked about this the
head of deter says they are so
overwhelmed with just paying legitimate
claims and other issues
they don't have time to get back to
everyone but if you've submitted the
proper documentation the issue is likely
being looked into reporting live vanessa
murphy 8 news now